okay so the course is at its core very
intensive nary so every single text that
we read includes at least two
disciplines so when we talk about say
linguistics we look at linguistics from
a very historical perspective but also
from a very social perspective so
basically we look at language and
society you don't just focus on language
per se and we do the same with found
with writing with literature with an
apology there is always a larger lens
that brings in at least two or three
disciplines so and plus we also bring in
guest speakers from various disciplines
having to do with the International
Studies at apology history of course
linguistics my own field but and also to
submit themselves they they come from
interdisciplinary background so some of
them are scientists but also others do
women's studies at apology biology so we
all I think in the course will prime to
look at these issues of of blacks in the
u.s. from a very interdisciplinary
perspective from the student perspective
if we think of this notion of
interdisciplinary I think many of them
come from from the science for example
so they're engineers I think we have
mostly engineers in the course and we
have also some scientists biology been
considered science and in these fields
often they look at particular problems
from very rich even narrow perspective
so I think that for many of them indeed
it may have been the first course they
did they took that exposed them to a
broad range of fields within one course